Ramadan Vlog Nummer 8 nachdem ich
gestern bei meiner Freundin waren wenn
Spielabend hatten habe ich die Flasche
im Auto noch weggeext dann die
Spülmaschine am Abend angeschmissen
damit ich sie am nächsten Morgen
ausräumen kann never ending story dann
habe ich meine diesjährige Bayram Torte
gemacht haben das sprich mal bitte für
mich aus ich kann es immer noch nicht
das heißt
Leute hier deutsch haben sie einfach so
richtig mit seinen Fingern an die Torte
egal ich habe dann einfach gekocht und
musste mich ablenken die Torte sieht auf
jeden Fall noch heile aus das Essen war
richtig lecker ich habe da gemacht und
jetzt bin ich gerade im Food Komma auch
wenn es gar nicht so viel war aber ja
ich bin auf jeden Fall glücklich